I want to get you caught up on something we
talked about at the start of the week, Fox News
comedy show, and I'm using that term very
loosely. Fox News comedy show Gutfeld
debuted on Monday night, and it's maybe the
least funny comedy show that I've ever seen.
And one of the questions I asked on Monday was
why does right wing comedy not work? Many of
you weighed in and I'm going to have some of
your thoughts in a couple of minutes. Somehow
in the first week, the show has gotten even
less funny. Check out a couple of these clips
from last night's episode. Here's these terms.
They're of questionable meaning. Here is a sketch
or a skit about how if the Masters golf
tournament is racist, then anything with
the word master is therefore racist. Take
a look how this voter ID law was racist.
Meanwhile, they still have the Masters,
right? Yeah, it's called the Masters.
If master bedrooms are racists, the masters
are racists, masturbation is racist, mastership
is racist, what is masturbation? I
don't know. Is your dad watching? Oh,
your dad's in the audience. Very good, Joe.
I am dying to find out what's in your brain.
Who thinks that's funny? The only funny thing
about it is I can't I can't think of anything
that's really funny about it. Now, one of
the big controversies around the Masters has
actually been that Augusta National Golf Club
doesn't allow women. And then that's getting
mixed up with the Georgia voter law stuff
which are, you know, racially suppressive
along along racial lines. The jokes don't even
make sense. Never mind being funny. For the
third night in a row, they did another segment
about CNN supposedly being obsessed with racism,
three nights running the exact same joke, even
though I don't even know what the joke is.
Vacation isn't the goal. Conflict is. And once
you see this framework, it shows up everywhere.
I mean, take a look at what's on CNN right now.
Grandmother farmer Randy Pseudolus,
grandma. She's all right for a racist.
Maybe the bear does have a
point there, the bears so racist
is a racist. So three nights in a row with
that one, I don't know if they can't come
up with anything better or they think that
that one's really working. It's not clear
if it was a good joke I could maybe see going with
it, like go with what works. This is not a joke
that's working. And I also am wondering, like, is
there really a studio audience or is the laughter
just employees who are hanging out in the room?
Because it sounds very, very sparse, like it's
all very strange, every detail if you were to if
you were trying to make a satire. Of right wingers
doing a comedy show, this is what a Saturday
Night Live skit about right wing comedy shows
would look like, but this is actually the show.
So now on to your comments. I asked on Monday,
why can't right wingers do comedy? Why doesn't it
work? And I got a bunch of interesting responses.
Many of you wrote to me and said, you know, David,
the reason, right? What you said, sir, the reason
right wing comedy doesn't work is because right
wingers want to watch news channels and get angry,
not watch news channels and laugh. I think
there's probably something to that to some
degree. Another idea is that right wingers become
motivated and activated by disinformation that's
presented as fact. So when they have
disinformation presented as comedy,
they're not sure like are we supposed to laugh?
Are we supposed to take it seriously or are we
supposed to rant and all caps on Twitter? Like,
what are we supposed to do as a result of this?
A bunch of people made some pretty
aggressive comments about intelligence,
saying, you know, if you're dumb enough to fall
for what Fox News reports as news. You probably
don't have the intelligence to understand comedy
or satire or parody, and it's the wrong audience.
In other words, the idea that an appreciation
of humor requires a level of intelligence that
your average Fox News viewer lacks, that's a very
aggressive statement for sure. But maybe there's
something to it you tell me. One person wrote in
and said the problem is that the jokes are both
lazy but too mean spirited. They you really need
them to be clever and slightly mean spirited,
like they're not calibrated correctly. One viewer
suggested that the problem is that it is humor,
but it's basically an adult version of the high
school bullies making fun of the one disabled
kid or the one black kid. So it just comes off as
like crass and inappropriate rather than funny.
That's a pretty interesting analogy,
actually. There may be something to that.
And then last thing, and there's a common thread
to all of this. Someone wrote to me and suggested
they're not really doing satire. They're
expressing the same contempt that they express
all the time in a way that they hope will
get people to laugh. And it just doesn't
work. I think there's something to all of these
critiques for sure. Let me know why you think
this right wing comedy idea is not working. Let
me know how long you think this show will last.
As I told you on Monday, the half hour news hour,
which was the last attempt at comedy by Fox News,
it lasted 17 episodes. I don't remember if that
was a weekly show or a daily show. 17 episodes
on a weekly show is 17 weeks. 17 episodes on a
weeknight show is like three and a half weeks.
I don't know. But tell me, how long do you think
the Gutfeld Show looks like it's going to last?